welcome to this video house of fun is my
opponent Victoire Chris nakuha
professional pianist okay cool so it's
not very exciting Tori a check of quads
it's super solid but also not
particularly interesting Bishop c4 is
some somewhat uncommon normally it
always goes to the three
breath preparing Bishop f8 that
regrouping Quincy seven then just em
basically black is going for a hedgehog
information one idea is to play 'if I've
ultimately which is not so easy in this
particular case and now he goes goes
back here with the bishop okay I always
like this funky move okay so he just
trade stuff so I'm going to play this
one and mostly technical means not
trying anything fancier when I tried
something fancy in recent games it's
mostly backfired let's just try normal
stuff now at five is played to gain
space control and you for okay yeah I'm
doing that again it's lodged at bishop
I'm happy to going be five here or not
as Bishop c5 at the end it's not that
it's not that clear 94 to have six also
clearly in the pollution
yeah it's interesting not entirely sure
what the best way to play is
really there's some other move then
Bishop takes you three and I would be
interested in learning what that might
be but he took his time so let's cover
here nitey form maybe ok now I'm happy
to go down as f4 is an additional
weakness h4h one sorry there should be
seven however is losing the six pawn so
that's not a great idea maybe this 15 of
g7 has roped gg1 probably is still he's
still very solid here meaning mostly
just shuffle TN this game but it's a
very tough position to break down this
is the nature really of this this kind
of openings Saudi five-year g5 he has to
go back basically 95 I'll take a five
and hence that's not good so he goes
back there should be seven
hmm interesting when I think I have to
do that
hmm now it definitely didn't didn't play
it the best way possible I still think
there's not much happening but I think
there should have been some way to play
for an advantage and this is not this is
not it yeah that that is rather more
comfortable for him I cannot do much him
I can play rookie 7 theoretically
speaking maybe it's not like playing for
windows so much I don't see why this
should be worse than the other move um
okay yeah night see 50 but I have you
five then and that i'm not sure about
I'd see if I v5 should be okay for me
ideas some rogue g7 yeah it's difficult
here right can I do something here
something active that can easily easily
backfire something like before also add
that rook invasion is some certainly an
annoying annoying prospect I wonder no I
didn't think about that move okay okay
it's not clear that this is bad for me
rookie three years a threat I don't
think that was great check check
let's think there is there something
better I don't think so let's take that
phone just keep it time warning check
well I think you he he's simply like he
wanted a bit too much from that position
he was fine but I think he tried to do
something that was not there my typical
mistake Bishop c5 is the idea to Toronto
fatigues butchy kid group t6 94-94 King
593 c3 and promotes am ok check check
check check
checkmate yeah I wanted too much now i
believe it was very very equal ish
unless I'm missing judging things here I
thought I mean around here around here I
definitely have something I mean not not
a lot but something because of the space
but I played it badly afterwards what is
the engines giving you Bishop g7 85 yeah
maybe I have to push that through I was
thinking getting the king and cannot be
that bad I mean it wasn't bad like in
inverse but and worse for me but
definitely not much to hope for yeah
maybe I should just go be five now him
let's it's possibly true yeah the engine
is always on equal or slight advantage
for wired you know this I mean ok
computer actually likes white erupt g8
hmm Butchie adis is better than this and
it's a bit of a passive Butchie eight is
better that has this additional idea
yeah that's much much better check and
he will win that porn check Oh
okay the root gain game they are almost
always some chances but that's not a
really great endgame challenge here at
tables turning at age five is a bad idea
looked it twisted okay this this and the
ops sorry and this and nothing much
happens yeah the way you played it in
quite fell apart maybe chat got a [ __ ]
I'm nervous by lack of time I don't know
okay well thanks for watching